one thing to really that is a great
liberator as an actor is listening
really learning how to listen I had to
learn that when I went to acting school
in fact I remember very well being
admonished rightfully so very directly
in one of the first scenes I did they
sort of sat me down and said you know
you're very busy you're very busy with
everything that you're doing but are you
really watching the other actor that
you're working with it made a huge
impression on me I noticed that I love
watching people listen I like it on the
stage as well if I go to a play I'm off
I'm often looking at the person who's
not speaking I don't know I've just got
that thing I the listening face to me is
a is fascinating and often if you think
about movies that you loved and you
think about moments in movies often the
person isn't speaking the person is just
taking something in and that's the
luxury of the camera and that's why it's
wonderful to work on camera
it's because the camera really comes to
you
when I think of the films especially but
it's like it represents a sort of part
of my life and and the films that aren't
even weren't necessarily successful or
not even seen maybe by very many people
they they inhabit a big part of me as
well because the process of doing them
is mine and the process of making it
however it turns out that's the only
part that's really mine I try to find
myself on uncertain ground in a good way
I try to cultivate that I'm lucky that I
get to do that so I made this film
that's about to come out called film
stars don't die in Liverpool and wow
that was such an adventure and I was
very much dependent on my partner Jamie
Bell who I played opposite I'm very
grateful to him we worked very closely
together it all starts with the writing
and if the writing is good
then that's what we need were just
interpreters as actors we we sometimes
we get to improvise and sometimes we get
to have them input but I mean I've never
written anything myself so we're
interpreters so I look at the writing in
movies certainly who the director is I
mean that's now when I was starting out
I was like whatever I could get it's
just like anyone I was auditioning for
whatever I could get an audition for and
taking pretty much what I could take but
uh yeah a great writing I think it it
all starts and ends there um something
different something new something I've
never done before when I started in New
York I was up for a pilot and I got the
job so I shot the pilot really feeling
like I didn't know what I was doing even
though I and I was a trained actress but
still cameras oh my god cameras marks
what does that even mean marks I didn't
know anything the big thing with the
pilot is is it going to go or not is it
going to be a series and the day comes
when you're finding out and I got the
call from my agent and he called Annette
they're picking up the series but
they're not taking you so that was an
option that I hadn't thought of so
basically I was fired and I was I'm
laughing now I was so devastated because
of my own insecurities I I was confirmed
all my insecurities were confirmed know
you thought maybe you weren't sexy
you're not and you're not funny and
you're not you're not you're not it you
don't know how to do it and you failed
and so anyway I got fired and I learned
a lot from that but it was a it was one
of those setbacks that kind of at them
at the time I really felt yeah but it
really was hard but then you know I got
through it and I learned a lot from it
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]